vielleicht sagt der weg den pool morgens
nimmt etwas über das ganze land aus
indien ist eine baustelle
eine gesellschaft noch immer im aufbau
die arbeit daran ist hart das ziel ist
ein autobahnkreuz am rande von delhi
darunter treffen sich die kinder der
nachbarschaft sie sind zum unterricht
verabredet lesen schreiben rechnen
lernen auf der großbaustelle um sie
herum wird gehämmert gebohrt geschweißt
ist das der richtige platz für bildung
es gibt keinen anderen derzeit nicht die
staatlichen schulen sind zu in corona
lockdown deshalb habe ich mir überlegt
ich komme jeden tag zweimal um weiter zu
lernen
morgens haben wir englisch am nachmittag
matte und wissenschaft so kann ich
meinen lehrplan einheiten
und so kann ich dann auch irgendwann
mein examen verstehen
nadal ist studierter
sozialwissenschaftler
er bewirbt sich gerade auf einen job in
einer regierungsbehörde die wartezeit
überbrückt er unter der brücke und
bietet sein wissen an freiwillig
unentgeltlich engagiert diese kinder
konnten jetzt seit vier fünf monaten
nicht mehr in ihre schule gehen
das ist richtig bitter für sie sie
kommen alle aus armen familien ihre
eltern sind analphabeten tagelöhner
feldarbeit
ohnehin ist der zugang zur bildung für
diese kinder schwierig aber corona hat
ihre bildungschancen nochmal stark
verschlechtert von amos mittags nach
hause
sie wird gebraucht auf dem feld
die ukraine sind reif müssen gepflückt
werden mutter und sie ist seit den
frühen morgenstunden dabei und erwartet
hilfe ich habe gestern bei der ernte
geholfen und heute auch wieder
ich mag die arbeit auf dem feld
überhaupt nicht aber mama will dass wir
kinder mitmachen dann gehts ja auch viel
schneller
mein bruder trägt das gemüse zu markt
ich habe immer nur gearbeitet ich war
mir auf einer schule das gab es für mich
nicht sechs kinder haben die komanis
alle müssen versorgt werden bis sie aus
dem haus sind hunan ist 15 jahre für
mutter und wie heißt das sie wäre reif
zu gehen wir haben hohe ausgaben um die
felder zu unterhalten
es reicht gerade so zum leben wir hätten
sie schon verheiratet aber uns fehlt das
geld für die aussteuer ohne mitgift
nimmt sie keine söhne bringen geld
töchter kosten welches und gelten
deshalb oft als last ihre bildung
scheint da überflüssig je ärmer die
familien sind desto ausgeprägter dieses
denken sowie kuhn am leben von den 1,4
milliarden indern viele in armut
abgehängt sind sie auch in anderer
hinsicht nur jede fünfte familie hat
zugang zum internet vor allem auf dem
land fehlt mal der strom übers netz oft
beides ein digitaler graben tut sich auf
corona vertieft ihn und die bildung der
kinder leidet warnen experten
indien hatte erhebliche fortschritte
gemacht gerade in den ländlichen
gebieten konnten deutlich mehr kinder
zur schule gehen
aber dieser digitale graben führt jetzt
dazu dass viele wieder völlig den zugang
zur bildung verlieren denn in vielen
regionen ist die digitale infrastruktur
nicht nur lächerlich es gibt schlichtweg
keine dabei scheint gerade jetzt in
zeiten der pandemie das internet
unverzichtbar
somit das so de begrüßt ihre schüler zum
online unterricht so mehr da ist
lehrerin an einer privatschule auch die
iss zu wägen corona aber übers internet
geht's weiter
für diese kinder schon das ist mehr
ausnahme als regel
das ganze land steht vor einer enormen
herausforderung
es fehlt an technik ausrüstung mobilen
geräten
da tut sich eine riesige kluft auf
zwischen arm und reich
kinder die keinen zugang zum internet
haben weil die mittel fehlen werden
zurückbleiben
bildung muss man sich leisten können ein
brutaler satz eine brutale realität hieß
familie kann es sich leisten gehobene
mittelklasse festes einkommen eine
wohnung mit strom natürlich und internet
klar an die 1000 euro im jahr kostet
eine gute privatschule viel geld in
indien für die meisten viel zu viel wenn
ich an die staatlichen schulen denke
dann bin ich so dankbar
ich fühle mich wirklich privilegiert
dass meine eltern mir all das bieten
können
die privatschule das laptop internet und
an staatlichen schulen bekommen die
kinder derzeit überhaupt kein unterricht
das muss wirklich schlimm sein
unter der brücke auf der baustelle des
lebens geht es tatsächlich ganz anders
zu es habe bisher keine corona fälle
gegeben heißt es masken seien nicht
nötig so lernen sie hier dicht an dicht
denn der abstand hält besteht nichts die
baustelle ist zu laut
sie machen eben das beste daraus denn es
steht viel auf dem spiel wenn ein kind
einen schultag verpasst dann holst du
das in einer woche sicher auch aber
jetzt wenn kinder vielleicht ein ganzes
jahr verpassen
dann verlieren sie jeden anschluss und
haben keine chance mehr eine chance zu
haben zumindest einen traum ist das
wirklich schon zu viel verlangt für eine
kindheit
ich will nicht wie meine eltern eines
tages auf dem feld arbeiten
ich will etwas lernen und ein besseres
leben haben
ich will etwas aus mir machen und ein
gebildeter mensch sein
lehrerin sei ihr traumberuf sagt kuhn am
kinder unterrichten chancen eröffnen
allen überall und sei es auf der
baustelle unter der autobahn wo sie für
heute einpacken aber morgen wiederkommen
denn morgen ist wieder schule